when we're doing the channel 9 show they  didn't have like designated uh  dressing rooms  and i'm in there changing into my you  know on-air outfit  and all of a sudden there was no lock i  don't think and all of a sudden the  doors open and gary's standing there and  i'm like  practically butt naked i don't know how  naked i was but i'm trying to cover  parts  always say i always say robin had three  things to cover but only two hands  but i was so terrified  yeah it was just like oh my god and then  he was like ah and he closed the door  and i'm like oh my god i don't know yeah  i don't know what just happened but i  still have to get ready to do the show  and go out and see gary  you